speaking of this extraordinary book that
i've been reading
um and i will forever have the chart
um that dr perry uh put in the book as
far as
the upside down triangle the upside down
triangle what you guys talk about
as far as the impression that children
are
left with at such an earlier age than i
think was
spoken about in at least my growing up
i i think even into almost having kids i
feel like
everybody kind of went they won't notice
when they're
when they're young and i i i did not
understand why that was the notion it
didn't seem right it didn't feel right
but i wanted to believe it because
that's what so many people had said
here's the bottom line that really was
the hugest
epiphany for me all these years i've
done
multiple shows where people say
exactly what you just said drew oh they
won't remember
you know i'm yes i'm in an abusive
relationship and as soon as
you know uh when the kids are young when
they get older i'm gonna move
i'm gonna get out of a relationship the
most damage is done
from zero to two months because that's
the time when the brain is taking in
everything and anybody who's ever had
children you all know this because
you get to watch that whole language
socialization process
how do they learn the word data how do
they learn mama how do they learn
spoon how do they learn so as they're
taking in all of that when the brain
is the most open and receptive they're
also taking in all the other stuff
that changed everything for me in terms
of
how people are raising their kids and
how we see
that what you do in front of the
youngest children matters
you know i have a question um which is
that uh when when i was born my dad
he had split with my mom and um i
i just didn't know him he was very
abusive he would come around he would
trash the house
uh he was scary um
and you know there are a lot of people
and you share um a story of what
happened
the first night that you stayed with
your mom in milwaukee
and for people who have
um had a parent one or two
that did not want to be in their child's
lives for whatever their reasons were
which is
valid to them very hard for a child to
understand
what do you talk through with yourself
or other people who have had that kind
of start
to their lives who deal with that kind
of trauma you talk about the eyes and
the being wanted and
the being set up right what happens when
you're not
so here's the here's the good news about
all of this
because all of us have had things to
happen to our enough to happen to us
in our lives that caused us to feel
unwanted and
not important everybody has at some
point in your life
even if you come from the best of
circumstances
it is possible to take your
post-traumatic
pain and turn that into post-traumatic
power and post-traumatic wisdom
i know this for sure that whatever has
happened to you
can also be for you
if you allow it to be the thing that has
healed me the most
is taking the pain that i endured
suffered survived as a child and turning
that
inside out so that is why i created my
school
specifically looking for girls who were
just like me
who came from poor backgrounds who came
from dysfunctional backgrounds
who many times felt unwanted unloved
how do i create an environment for them
how do i give
back this is how you save yourself how
do i give
back that which i was not given
and when you can do that you begin to
fill the hole
inside yourself that giving back
has become really what my legacy is and
i will share this with you that
i was sitting with maya angelou after
i'd come back from the opening of my
school
and i said oh this is going to be the
school this is going to be my greatest
legacy
i mean these girls this is this is this
is this is what my life was for and she
said you have no idea
what your legacy will be and i said oh
no no no no my you
she should have been there it's i'm
telling you that's going to be the
school
and she said i said you have no idea
what your legacy will be your legacy is
every life you touch your legacy isn't
your name on a school
or any other building your legacy is
every life you touch so i say this to
you drew barrymore
your legacy this is what maya said to me
everybody who's ever watched a show
and decided i'm going to go back to
school i'm going to go on a diet
i'm going to treat myself better i'm
going to leave an abusive relationship
every life that you have touched
that has experienced your voice and the
power of your platform
that is your legacy
and that is why in oprah we trust and i
just want to say
also that you said here's the good news
that to me is one of the most positive
and powerful ways in which to engage
people's minds and hearts
because it is so hopeful
you